the first is ready drone strikes hit
Janine shortly after one o'clock on
Monday morning
the Israeli military says they hit a
joint Operation Center which was a
meeting and Sheltering point for wanted
terrorists
by Dawn army vehicles were on the
streets of the City closing off roads
and shutting Janine down
there are around a thousand Israeli
soldiers involved in the operation
they eliminate terrorists they arrest
wanted persons they destroy headquarters
and seize many weapons they destroy
laboratories on an almost industrial
scale Laboratories from which they
created explosives intended for the
slaughter and murder of Israeli
civilians
heavily armed bulldozers were sent in to
counter the threat from roadside bombs
and clear the streets tearing up the
tarmac to make it harder for militants
to move around
and Israeli soldiers have not holed
through walls to make sniper positions
residents in Janine were sent text
messages
urging them to stay indoors at the same
time calls were made from the mosques
encouraging people to fight and defend
the city
ambulances rushed to help the wounded
and collect the dead I can't sleep
because all this noise and all these
bombs around us I can't move because the
Israel army they are occupied all the
streets they don't allowed for us to
move at the same time it's really it's
it's dangerous to move Israel Target any
person he just move so we can't be in
the in their face or we can't be in the
live by normal way understand our home
as curfew as I I mean we can't move we
can't move it's not allowed for us to
move
the operation was approved after a
series of events in recent weeks four
Israelis were shot dead at a petrol
station in the West Bank
and a few days ago this video was
released by Palestinian militants
attempting to fire homemade Rockets into
Israel
the message from the idea is that this
is a limited operation to restore
deterrence and they don't expect it to
widen Beyond Janine into other parts of
the West Bank
they won't put a time limit on it but
most people expect it to last a few days
alistabunga Sky News in Jerusalem